hey guys in this video we're going to talk
about how to fix hunchback okay you know the
person that has this like Buffalo Hump back here
now let me differentiate now you actually have a
fat pad in the back I'm not really talking
about the fat pad I'm talking about really
severe poor posture and we're going to show you
the best way to do with that but the first thing
to know is there's a vertebra called c7 and
it's the seventh vertebra in your neck it's
at the bottom part and what you have to know is
that that one is normally sticking out a little
bit more than the rest so if you think that's
abnormal it's not everyone has a very large c7
vertebra okay so want to point that out also
if you have a lipoma that is a fatty tumor
sometimes that could be on your back creating
a little hunchback in which case you may want
to get to surgically removed because it's really
difficult to get rid of that okay but I'm talking
about the person with really bad posture and what
happens is that when you're slouched like this on
the inside of your spine there is a ligament and
there are muscles that are too tight and they're
pulling you forward all the chest muscles are too
tight and they're pulling you forward so when your
parents would tell you to sit up straight that
was actually bad advice because every time you
would stretch this all you're doing is you're
stretching that rubber band and it's going to
come right back okay well your parents should
have told you is to do the opposite okay so in
this next part I'm going to show you the best
stretch for reversing this hunchback and I want
you to do it right now as you're sitting there
and then put your comments below because it's
pretty cool okay the first thing to not do is
sit up tall stretch backwards we don't want to
do that because all the tightness is on the front
part of the body or the inside of the spine on the
front part so what we want to do is you want to
stretch the back part which will send electrical
signals to the front to relax it and just kind
of demonstrate this so tuck your heads forward
as much as you can now slouch you upper back all
the way down yeah that's right all the way down
yeah is exactly what your the opposite of what
your parents told you to do right you said sit
up tall no you actually tell the child to slouch
more so okay let's do it again tuck your head forward
all the way and we're actually hunched your back
we're trying to make her back more hunched its
hunches you can get it and it's actually going to
stretch all this and relax all that tightness on
the front part and it's every time she does this
she's going to come up more and more and more and
you're probably not going to believe me until you
do this on yourself I'm going to do it like five
to ten times do this like once a day slouch all
the way down yeah that's right good you're going
to hold that stretch good come back up and what
you're going to notice it's easier to come up more
and more and more and so I'm not saying you can't
stretch back but this is the key move to allow you
to bring you out of that hunchback state all right
go ahead and try this and put your comments below